gray is with us in Canada hi gray
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show oh
thanks for having me sure I'll gonna
help ya so I'll have a question so back
in 2013 I lost my dad and shortly after
I made the huge mistake of cosigner with
my mom and my brother for a medical
school for my brother he was a five next
five to six years I was always giving
money to my family because I was single
I was giving money never prioritize my
needs or what I felt to do in the
situation so I got married two years ago
and of course i'm priorities shifted and
i had a child and you know we started
planning for our family our future and
two months ago we bought our home all
the native decent income so now my
family just demanding for money so
dramatic for money even when I've told
them I don't have much because I just
came off Matt leave a year ago and I'm
still with they're trying to get our
finances why do they think they have a
right to your money exactly I wasn't it
wasn't a passive-aggressive statement
I'm curious whose parents or brother or
sister think they have a right to your
money to demand from you that's so
strange is strange and it's led to mean
calling and I've dispensed myself as I
feel very toxic and I've chosen to
prioritize my family time my needs my
brother who is 29 found in medical
school a zombies know that I co-signed
on him she stole the money lots of money
cos he mismanaged funds I mean back when
I was 19 my dad died I was very
vulnerable
I didn't understand what co-signing
really meant but I did it because I
thought it was out of a good place to
help them out
but and now I'm left with you know
monthly payments that they're not
keeping their own side of the bargain so
I want to maintain a good credit and
much of this medical dad do you oh it
was two hundred and twenty thousand
thirty cosines in Canada in Canadian
to school in the state it was not how we
planned it it was meant to be less than
that but he kept you today you owe
$220,000 on your brother's medical
school all of us we have it shared and
my brother myself and my mom now I know
much better and now I understand what it
means to co-sign what rudderless assumed
responsibility really is and I have to
bear the consequences of decisions I
mean but you keep asking and it's caused
lots of insults and I've visited myself
but I don't know why - oh but they have
I have to do everything I have to get
out of med school graduate from med
school extra fun and I can't do anything
about it I feel like he owes the school
money so they won't give him the diploma
exactly more money and I'm explained to
him now I have this a priority I cannot
do this year he can try and next it but
he has to work you know he has to work
his 2930
everything's been given to him every
time but he hasn't really had that sense
of responsibility yeah well here's the
problem okay your but your family's
toxic and they have boundary issues
without a doubt they there's all kinds
of just relational violations here and
this it's just so sad to listen to so
when people think they have a right to
things that are over and you're inside
your boundaries and then you put up a
boundary and say no they almost always
react with anger people people who feel
entitled and you tell them that they're
not they're almost always reacted with
anger and so that's what happens when
you put up a boundary it's just standard
process so
your this is not going to get better
it's going to get worse and there's
probably going to be a huge blow up at
some point but that none of that means
that you need to pay the money you don't
I wouldn't pay a dime on this stuff I
would let us sit over there and rot
there's enough no reason that you should
have been on this loom and there's no
reason that you should pay it except
that you now are legally obligated and
so you may have to go back and clean up
something there at some point to get it
off of your family your immediate family
not your brother and your mother but
this is silliness that they get to
demand money from you so you just need
to be real quiet and real calm and real
firm and just say listen I love you and
I'm just not going to be paying on this
and I'm not gonna be sending you guys
money and I'll send you a copy of Henry
clouds book boundaries it is the the
consummate book on this subject and he
sold tens of millions of copies of this
book because every family every
relationship almost always has some kind
of a boundary thing in it and just
learning to navigate that helps all of
us with our relational IQ our ability to
relate to others in a healthy way and
it's called growing up and it sounds
like your mom never did so hold on I'll
send you a copy of that book and help
you out